okay for Jordan people joining this
livestream we are in part of a somewhat
high-pressure series of meetings about
12:1 functionality which will be
continuing over the next few days and
beyond
right now we're talking about geometry
and graphics and these are these are
complicated agendas and we may or may
not get through everything in the time
we have available here all right first
thing shadows this is exciting how do I
see this if you use 12:1 prototype it
should just work so if you go to the
reference page there should be an exam
if for toon shading for instance sitting
then you could pick you know just pick
any example you can see you so I can
just go here so this is now in addition
to Sophie okay so if I put in something
more complex we had Taurus primitive
here no okay we certainly have a
dodecahedron we do that's not that
exciting because that's just gonna have
flat I see it's gonna be flashy there
right like you know not data you can see
does not engage data oops
what do I say a geometry trifle not
geometry or something what should I ask
for here next weekend taking its time
thing this one has too many polygons ok
so let me try another kind of shading
that's not a very good trading I want to
try oh let's try let's try hatch hatch
shading that sounds good now what why
well that's revealing its ribbing
okay stipple shading how about that that
should be cool it should look like The
Wall Street Journal actually if you yeah
that's a pretty weird effect when you
rotate it I don't know whether I've ever
I mean cuz it's because what I'm seeing
there the stippling is remaining in the
same place even as the geometry is
moving yeah but the question is where
the lights were sits so it it's like a
light source that's shooting out pieces
of stipple no but what is it because
that's what it seems like it seems like
it's fixed relative to the light sources
the stipple pattern is fixed relative
the light sources yes will achieve to do
window screen we can make it I mean
hopefully followed coverage omate way
that you know then when you do the
rotation you'll actually work but East's
we thought that the stepping effect is a
kind of aesthetic effect you want to
apply to a static object an object
rotate it was the balance between the
performance and of course we want I want
to see something here this would be very
exciting if this actually works I had no
idea I was waiting for this for like
years hmm yes what I almost put them 0.1
or something the default case wait what
why doesn't it I want to make much finer
hatching I haven't yet implemented that
da city so after the design will
actually do that correctly just taking
the angle prototype
okay no there's no way we're gonna call
it tiling not a chance but we Stoke up
crazy background noise I know what it is
say take an image okay can I do that in
3d no it's 20 just working today we
should be able to do it in 3d and what
determines the size relative to the
thing I saw in possibly take a second
argument which should be yes so it's
what we have to fix quickly we're taking
the density okay so this idea that we're
gonna have all these different functions
seems wrong this is more like image
effect right yes we went down to that
thought of just having one function
without really different specifications
image effect as well I mean how how
locked down are these particular kinds
of functionality
did you understand my question
not really well I mean if I were to look
over the past 25 years
what kind of shading people have used
right just a bling one certainly heard
of you know cross-hatching one certainly
heard of but
can't have hatch and hatching right
I mean these somehow have to be unified
I don't understand why this is even
different I mean the hatching the heart
shedding that way all of them end with
shading it's essentially the effect of
the light on the object is that shading
effect as opposed to the hatching which
is the trick property of the object but
could you not have a hatching I mean
could this have had chicken
where you put the Taurus itself have a
hatching pattern didn't update the
screen so you mean during the drawing
oh no no I I understand even if I you're
the screen is not updating but the
question is can you know there's
something that's intrinsic to that
surface we were discussing that there
are all kinds of other spec problems
it's related to what we do with textures
and we're gonna look at that we were
hoping to get to that now but we'll be
412 to where we're going to look at
various texture mappings easy to use
standardized texture mapping to advanced
right I mean let's talk about this for a
second okay so first point you could
have a notion of hatching as well that
this cuts out of a sort of a 3d shape of
things yes because otherwise I mean
obviously if you just try to you know
comb the hair so to speak you're gonna
get horrible home atopic issues right
right
and so we definitely don't want to set
ourselves up for that that presumably
right but it's unavoidable you get those
impossible issues with texture mapping
I mean you I understand that I mean as I
understand it there are two fundamental
approaches to texture mapping
one is you you know when you have a you
know you can either unroll the surface
and try and take your 2d thing and stamp
it onto that unrolled surface or you can
say you know I've got in each of the
three directions X Y Z or something I am
projecting some image onto the texture
onto the object from that direction
that's sort of correct you know so the
standard texture mappings are like that
like sphere mapping cylinder mapping
cube mapping and so on that's that's the
projecting on you know from surrounding
images basically um right so actually
there's several comments on our live
stream here um
complained that the tiling thing is
really filling which it certainly is um
a question from Ali ASCII and new
functions coming for polyhedron
polyhedra intersection function to see
if two polyhedra are colliding yeah what
are we doing there for drawing the seam
line between polyhedra did you
understand my question yes first we are
concerned of polyhedra is solid now the
brace aim confusion in the old
literature polyhedra because they
couldn't do solid modeling properly so
they just intersect two surfaces and
then the question is what you talk about
are you talking about the surface or
you're talking about to solve it so hold
on if we if we just take graphics 3d um
of two icosahedra for example I would
imagine I can say like point five point
eight or something here oops point zero
for instance okay so here we go okay so
in there you see what I'm talking about
in there clearly we've got color
difference but we don't have I mean you
know to two things we don't have in this
picture one is we don't have the ability
I mean I could go to an opacity here but
we wouldn't have the beautiful stuff
that you know is in old books and so on
where the obscured lines that are dotted
in the
in the opacity am i making sense right
um I mean is that anything that we're
going to get in long lines of this
photorealistic rendering stuff uh
non-photorealistic rendering okay so
that's a total mess so you you see what
I'm talking about I mean so like I got
two questions here first of all the seam
line there and second of all the you
know the dotting of these obscured
surfaces obscured edges that would be
that's a totally different projects okay
fine
all right I'm just asking I'm just
trying to understand and if you write
your own I mean it's possible it's
doable with Z buffers too but if you
write your own hidden surface
elimination algorithm and full data
structures for that I think you can kind
of do whatever you want but you're not
gonna be using a lot of graphics
libraries them so it's I know what am I
doing here is this is this working
whatever this is doing so that that
directive does everything that comes
after it writes but somehow it applies
to things before it here no no I give it
a style oh I didn't see the thought yeah
so okay so this is this is basically it
is being shot by little stibbles from
its light sources correct because those
tuples don't move as I move the object
right there from fixed to the light
sources right I think so do screen yes
okay which is kind of weird not what I
would expect it when you were to the
object yes but we can't change that if
needed but it's just that for this
stippling effect what you expect is a
fixed object which discipline give you
the 3d effect so we just had to make a
balance as I said before between the
performance right so we can make it
follow the you know use actual geometry
to normal and the west's understate
expensive and similar also do the
problem of texture mapping right you
will end up to that tool you'd be kind
of expensive to figure out why the white
mapping under to do white operation okay
hey wait a minute the is this a GPU
played is this whole thing I and yes I
notice you two is on this call so can
you explain what that you're going on
here yeah currently the word typeset as
some surface ferrous which contains like
a GPU shaders it's called the GS lawn
shader and we take that and we explain
that to render that and they do I use
GPU directly so with it I mean okay so
I'm trying to understand so for example
what's the most impressive of these
shaders I don't know what these look
like I mean if I say the gooc shading I
mean so if you look at the documentation
of the page we'll have some example that
would kind of try to give an idea you
know what one key part of those shader
no photo should it is that see there is
a light effect on our light system it
kind of doesn't actually show you need
to actually change the light to a more
directional light to be able to produce
effects so I have a question and I
assume that the attached cell that we
are hopefully working on for 3d graphics
will have light changing stuff in it
do you know who's working on that I do
not I didn't know I didn't know we were
working on that for 3d graphics right
now just because of other priorities
so yeah III think that I think that it's
in the cube but it's not actively being
worked on because of so you know we
should include other attached cells by
the way right maybe we should add this
since to young Noah's list of attached
cell activities this might be a rather
easy one compared to some of the other
ones he's trying to do I know the
mechanics have actually implemented or
straightforward but the interface may
not be well the one thing we could
certainly implement easily is some just
selecting particular cases just being
able to reflect you know just being able
to click through ten different light
source configurations so can we feed
that please I'm not sure who know her is
now working with he was working with
Brett but I thought that had been moved
well when they don't move because well
we were talking about him working with
Jeremy instead okay but Tim is the one
that's developed a lot of editing tools
okay well you guys sorted out I I don't
know doesn't matter to me
doesn't matter who he's working with I
mean that what matters is that there's a
good review cycle because he was working
with Billy and design to actually get
these some palettes you know iterated I
see um he showed the thing he has for
drawing tools which surely looks quite
nice um okay
in any case let's come back to this so
can somebody take that is Andrea your
your hair yes thank you
um
okay so explain this to me a little bit
more so this so do these these are there
are many things one can do with shaders
so the let's let's start the one end
let's start at the GPU side since you
asked about that
yes OpenGL direct3d and metal all have
effectively programmable language that
allows you to tell how to you know I'm
right
you know what color every pixels gonna
have and and those are little programs
that is very good for developers but
it's totally useless for developer for
you you know for end-users program those
things and it needs to interface with
our actual rendering loop so what we've
done is to curate it an initial set of
such shaders that we think are useful
and explainable right there's an
obviously an infinite set the possible
ones but these are ones that we think
are useful one that we hope to get to
eventually is for instance material in a
you know load which can give reasonable
looking material right but this seems
more important in terms of visualization
and illustration capabilities which is
what we more do then like game scenes
yeah right I know a furry furry sphere
is amusing but not necessarily what we
care about immediately right but even if
it's that gold or some kind of metal or
things like that we'll get all that but
it's the scene although I thought that
many of those things were I mean you
know I don't know what the state of the
art is these days but I mean it used to
be there were just you know Phong
shading parameters and things like there
wasn't it wasn't that difficult the
specification of most of the materials
other than things like fur and so on
we're not that complicated it is pretty
complicated and we gonna are we gonna be
a sort of inner license situation where
we need to get and now for that quality
material properties to be able to
emulate them can't remember exactly what
the details was okay it's a be she has
built the biggest such materials
database
different opposed to do that I mean
there is a physical base model weight
which we can use other is the data base
in one based on you know pure data we
can use so these just two different at
least two different implementation with
prototype so nevertheless so even it
produces GPU underneath which means you
will go fast on all platforms even if
you use a slightly different shader
language what's this all platforms I
mean depending on what kind of GPU how
now Apple is using something called
methyl they disk they are not
maintaining their OpenGL very good
anymore and Windows is using direct I
really I didn't know it was that bad
what's happened to so somebody was
telling me about this Vulcan thing
what's that that's yet a different it's
sort of a lapful been OpenGL z-- future
play but not something that balkans
platform is Linux but it has a software
rendering problem and software rendering
matters to us because we run on servers
that don't necessarily have video cards
so what we through this so what what are
the actual things though what but but
Rogers core point is that these shaders
they're written in shader languages I
know the language is actually different
for metal and for OpenGL and for
direct3d right so we are giving certain
parameterised versions of these four
particular named shading configurations
right I think that's the plan right now
is OpenGL I mean we're designing things
that we think we could deploy you know
identically on direct3d in mouth um okay
the bunch of comments on our live stream
which I want to want to ask about here
um our new functions coming for
polyhedra and somebody's asking about
polyhedra intersection function to see
if - poly holy hater intersection
function is region intersection so if I
take two random polyhedra
you know what the parameters are what
how many oh well I don't know how many
it gave there what do I put in this the
parameters here so ten of those and I
take another random polyhedra and
fourteen of those and now I say so what
am I gonna do here I'm saying region in
section percent eighty three and percent
eighty four okay and now if I say
graphics 3d of that okay I can tell her
to I mean I'm assuming that's right but
so what what's the hold on a second um
region intersection see if two polyhedra
are colliding what seems to work does
that did not work before 12.1 yes I did
but
sort of a you know it is a spatial
relational I see I see I see so the
question here being asked is he wants a
boolean to say say if two random
polyhedra are intersecting or colliding
right and so I think we had that as a
spatial relation already so we have
region but what would it be region I
thought we had a region intersecting Q
or some such other thing region disjoint
Q not Q because it's an intensity to
give conditions back Q functions become
liars when their parameters involved
yeah I understand so okay so if I say
region disjoint but sent 83% 84 why
doesn't that work
what's not work well there was a set of
four shown in 12 where we didn't
complete the full implementation that's
possible so that's the issue I think
here that is what our user is asking
about okay so the question is when will
region destroyed for polyhedra work it
must know what it must know the answer
here I mean it clearly could work in the
very worst case it finds out whether the
region intersection is is empty yes so
we'll make it work is more complicated
than debug that will make it work okay
good thanks okay so now Bob is saying in
the differential geometry did you text
your mapping yeah um
vector field on a curved surface like
drawing a weather map on a globe that is
coming separately with with Geographics
3d which I doubt is in this review is it
no no okay um let's see
Oh
was asking about performance and whether
you put this in a manipulated and I just
demoed that you certainly can someone's
asking about ray tracing
you know we've thought about putting ray
tracing into the system for 30 years and
every time we seriously think about it
it's like nobody really cares is that a
fair statement Roger yeah it's I mean in
other words you there a system there you
know if we've got good exporting then
you know if you really want a completely
photorealistic thing you know render it
in something which has really good ray
tracing yeah one thing that we said now
we do actually have good export
functions both to render man and random
and have very high-quality renderer and
pas vrai or POV so and we writing their
work
I'm sorry their workflows yes that
showcases those those things so if I
were to take for example this kind of
thing if I had to take that for instance
and I would say um export that - well
let's just I just wanna see what it
looks like
export that - what is it called povery
yeah actually I want to take that thing
to POV is that gonna be just a total
disaster Oh what the heck's that that
doesn't look very good that doesn't look
right well I think
right except there's no shapes exactly
now maybe maybe the opacity messed it up
or something but I can't see why it
would have done this probably is
probably a really old form we haven't
updated to add the support of the new
construct oh yeah that's my guess too by
the way I should say on the ray tracing
thing as real-time ray tracing starts to
become a thing I mean you two and I have
been keeping an eye on this and I you
know I haven't really floated it as a
major priority yet because we have a lot
of other stuff in the queue which you
know I think rightly takes priority but
it's something we're keeping an eye on
you know so Nvidia is trying to
introduce real-time ray tracing and it's
right now it's to a large extent I think
it's a means of selling their cards the
high-end cards well can you blame them
yeah no I can't blame them but but I
think that that will migrate sort of
over time that will migrate into a
broader set of cards and all of that and
yes and maybe even even on the Mac but
they are not using Nvidia cards so you
know yeah I wish they'd make peace
within video help um anyway the can
somebody please take a note the POV
thing who gets to fix the POV thing just
make it a bug report it's still in the
same team okay um look but it should be
a bug report you want to keep track of
all this okay so I would send it to
after a final time go to the people here
um try rib I mean I think it's just the
style style and opacity if you just put
sphere or stuff he will just work the
pastor doesn't manage to get told your
hopper leather style the rapper it's
here probably not work
in other words this has been poorly
maintained yes
magnificent okay that is but that looks
plausible looks more plausible than the
other things we saw okay fine so they're
just bugs there okay so let's come back
to talking about the surrendering stuff
oh boy have we got so much to go through
I as I said I thought um Wow
okay all kinds of exciting things here
hmm well okay uh what on earth is that
web region search is a very bizarre name
for that okay any case sorry um let's
let's go back up the web audio search
I'm aware but I just think it's very
it's it's a web image search I know that
I know that Roger except that we're not
usually used foot to the idea of you
know it's like the Thingiverse is not
the region bus although I admit that but
it is saying it is where we call it
geometry search first but that's too
broad so I really need to look at that
okay
let's and we're back to shade us here
okay so the first question is what is
the space of named shaders is that is
this a small piece of the space of named
shaders or is this a decent chunk of the
space of named shaders this is a decent
chunk of the none fo not NPR shaders
okay and if we look at physically
realistic shaders then what do we see we
see a bunch of material property shaders
but then do we see a whole lot of other
stuff physically bizarre hopefully
effect of materials is which much of
material wants so you okay so but to me
these really feel like effects of some
kind now you're concerned that they have
parameters right yes correct
so I I think these should be in some
Association or something the parameters
should be there I just don't think we
should have a bunch of
functions for you know random weird you
know shaders I mean especially this is
really pretty arbitrary I mean I don't
what I mean in that universe of shader
when you are their dissolute arbitrary I
mean this has kind of this turned I want
the tomb shedding is a standard you know
it's kind of the really meant that one
well okay so well Roger you've obviously
thought about this so you you have come
to the conclusion that we should
actually have these as named special
function like things in the system I
started exactly like you do saying
exactly what you said if Charles recall
yes took most convincing us okay all
right fine I'll see if I can perform
better um no but but seriously go ahead
so you can answer my benefit as well one
problem that I see with having
differently named things is that they
can't cooperate with one another that
you know you can't have something that's
halftone gooped or something like that
why not you can put them I mean it is
essentially like like the Hachi white it
is you know if you cover the stuff with
hatching but if you want to give two
different I Heidi which all posit
shouldn't expect it to work
okay so I mean the question is is it
would it match if if you were to run the
shader code in the GPU for one of these
things and you run the shader code for
the other thing on each polygon what
does it actually do synthase beautiful
color if you do hair blue blue stick
precedents and is that generally true
for what the GPU would do or is it is it
like it just starts from a blank slate
and then fills in whatever shading it
fills in or can it take the state that
comes out of one shader and put it into
another trader yes kind of like a status
so so then you are answering that a
gooch halftone makes sense or are you
not you get what I'm saying
well I mean it seems to me that is
possible but you have to be careful how
you develop the shaders to make sure you
don't but I don't I mean back to what
you said I don't see how that changes
whether we have separate symbols are
there one symbol with many string names
in it I don't see how that changes that
at all that well I think it's slightly
nicer to compose it if actually I think
it's nicer to compose it if they are
separate symbols because you can imagine
some functional composition types but
but see it's the effect on the surface
we cannot define two different effect on
the surface on guess that you know play
with your lights okay what does the
shader what is the input to a shader
these guys I mean yeah we are thinking
more about this kind of giving it the
high D for an effect on the surface is
really an not dependent on the [ __ ]
for me the shader is more the language
you use not so implemented in twenty
years maybe no one uses anymore shadows
fair enough
no but with these these ones that are
called you know xxx shading right now
what they all use is basically a single
luminosity component of the computed
color value on the surface and that
computed color value on the surface has
gone through a what we call our standard
shader in the language so wait a minute
so what this is doing is it's taking the
2d image is that correct that has been
generated by doing the you know 3d to 2d
transformation and it's taking that and
it is in this case line half toning it
is that correct that's right so but it
it what I'm saying is that it's you
today an initial the value that drives
dis effect
okay so luminosity value right so it
comes out of their color computation
yes gala field there's effectively a
scalar field at each point of the of the
of the 2d projected object yeah
everything is 2d when we look at it like
this sure no but I mean the shade is
operating the 2d representation is on
the 3d object so essentially what what
we do it you know we take do but it you
know eight point on the surface 3d
object you know value like indicate the
case of the tongue shading we actually
quantifies it so we put it in a discrete
set on this from the discrete said that
we under that you know to the screen off
you be projected in 2d object okay okay
but so so this so I understand the the
function what does it get at every point
of the surface every point of the 3d
surface it gets what it's getting some
luminosity value that's deduced from the
from the light yes sliding from guro
shading like we that could discuss ten
years ago where we did six yes use the
for shading which is okay so we use an
improved version of that thought okay
and I affectionately assuming certain
who's got an exponent right kind of yeah
it's sort of all fake but it's the
difference between guru and Fung is that
it interpolates the normal across the
surface patches yes where is the guru
you know uses doesn't it interpolates
the color value across them as opposed
to normals right okay let's zoom out for
a second what we're trying to achieve
here so I mean the first point is okay
so one thing that's still really
bothering me is the fact that this is
locked to the screen as opposed to
locked to the object well we've done six
dot I mean well can we or is it a
performance issue we can fit that in
quite now it's just an internal option
the performance is essentially to based
on the object essentially we'll have to
use the normal and computation and there
is a cost to pay for that what do people
think is I mean to me it seems very
bizarre that it's locked so Sandra our
live stream is asking whether this will
work
yeah we work really what the heck is
that
oh that's a plot that's an ordinary plot
yeah that's that's really cool isn't it
that's really cool if you if you only
had the hatching a little bit more
that's a wise so what about half toning
here I what about I mean there are many
different hatching patterns right I mean
Tim could give us a whole on that I mean
what's this oh maybe I'm looking at the
wrong no that's right
what is that possible if they're
hatching new or something that function
this morning can you send me the page
yes this is incredibly cool this is
really useful III mean that the one in
3d is amusing but this is really useful
I've wanted this for years um Bob on our
live stream is saying it's the half
toning would be useful for sending this
to printers from the 1950s not only
1950s you know even 1970s um okay I
don't know what happened to your page
something is wrong with your page there
okay so now what what is the
parameterization so essentially we first
thought that do you'll be the angle we
assume first that everything is just
parallel line does the stand are
hatching but we should have names for
these things like cross hatching
herringbone when I get it from CVS I get
the correct page I can what something's
wrong okay Andrea could you report that
to Roger please let the other Roger okay
the other Roger yes because this Roger
is right here um be okay okay so but
right you agree that there should be
names for this like herringbone and so
on yes yeah string names but so how do I
get something which is much finer
hatching we haven't implemented it okay
so this is so this is still fictional
here yes okay um
okay um okay all right
I really think by the way that
emphasizing these getting these 2d
things working really really well is
super worthwhile um okay but so I don't
have a problem with this concept of
hatching here with string names inside
the tiling name is just absolutely not
going to make it so let's take a look at
what that even is so that is you you've
got an object and you're filling with
that thing right right this so they're
called what would I call in PDF and SVG
start on pattern uh-huh do you like that
no um I mean maybe they were called
tiling pattern I can't remember spot and
ceiling Oh
tiling right that's pretty weird pattern
filling
um I mean filling would be better so
what the heck is that
what is filling well the
concept in oh that's an option it's an
option for yeah we know what filling is
or bad fit right yes well there is
already a filling sure and is what you
use on the plot upstairs yes okay so so
we need a name for essentially taking
these patches and tessellating these
patches correct yes and that name should
also work for the 3d case presumably
where you can also presumably tessellate
patches to cover some polygonal IgG
analyzed surface am i right yeah so that
leads to the same discussion we just had
about surface wrapping surfaces on top
of objects right takes your mapping plus
order more no I see I agree we're not
gonna get it instantly I just want to
get the design the same because it's
extremely non-trivial to see how you do
the patches given that you're wrapping
something you know the rectangular hello
pattern around you know tile around the
trefoil knot how does it possibly work
exactly right where the seams how does
it all work and that's gonna be a mess
yes but I think that what we're gonna do
sorry your carve out thing where the
thing is is sculpted out from a 3d you
know Swiss cheese or whatever it is
whatever the texture is right if we were
to sculpt this out of Swiss cheese it
would have an implied texture it would
we would have to do the experiments and
see whether it actually is useful I mean
it's presumably gonna look like a
photorealistic thing of somebody taking
you know pumice rock or something and
you know and still you know with
anything visual we'd better prototype
and test before we know I agree but in
the 2d case there's still many degrees
of freedom if you imagine tessellating
something well again it's no I guess not
I guess it's a stamp is that correct I
mean you basically have a tessellation
in you're stamping out of the
tessellation
this thing is that correct yes so I mean
what about the possibility of
tessellated since that would give us in
the case where somebody wanted to have
graphics of tessellated of now I don't
know what shapes you can have here that
that will tessellate so to speak I mean
one thing that I pushed for early on and
and I'm just a question of time before
you come up with the same idea here
which is that we should you know that we
could have in a more regular
semi-regular tessellation but it very
much complicates the design now but but
the thing is also the gold white I mean
solution so essentially you want to draw
it this way the surface its have pretty
much nothing to do with guys could you
explain to me you've got a unit cell
here and you are tessellating with that
unit cell what is the tessellation that
you are doing with that unit cell in the
case of those hellos it was tessellating
right that is doing what is that doing
that's simply that's doing some kind of
rectangular tessellation right it's
taking go it's it's always doing the
rectangular tessellation songs
okay so so it is a tessellation but it's
just a square tessellation basically yes
a deformed square tessellation but if I
would take for example here if instead
of hello there I were to take like an
ice I see if I were to take graphics of
disk for example then it would take the
squared disk that was a little weird the
the square disk form and I see an
tessellate those and then cookie cutter
the thing out of that tessellated form
right
[Music]
uh okay so your point is Roger don't
don't sign up for full tessellation
because always work being doing Kepler
tessellations and who knows what you
know Kepler tilings and who knows what
else yeah you know and I think you know
looking at sort of you know one thing
that it was useful also for us to be
slightly compatible with things like SVG
and other vector languages right but
okay so what would you call this thing
I think we have anybody any graphic
design person in here I maybe we could
find somebody and ask them what what
does anybody know what it's called in
that field I dragged you see if Jeremy
is around I can check on I try to see
Billy what Billy's not thrown okay Oh
Chris Brody okay I don't see Jeremy
online either um okay but but what we go
to invent is the thing here called fill
with patterns generally see that in a
drawing tool to you can I know in the
surface with a pattern yup I know that
what could we call it
I mean filling pattern is a I mean
you've got hatching and I guess the
analog of that will be pattern filling
but that's BA I mean texture is a word
we've already used for something rather
lame hatching pattern filling
I guess pattern filling is the least bad
of the things I'm seeing so far um see
I'm just looking for good okay so I'm
thinking okay so in terms of what it
contains here I mean all of the stators
and ours is very it is going to be very
obscure I think what you really need is
a coarseness measure look what are you
really going to need for hatching you
need coarseness which i think is
important and i think you need the
pattern the hatching pattern I'm making
sense of which cross hatching you know
the default I suppose is one way
hatching I mean I could imagine left
right things like that cross hatching
herringbone I think that's what that's
called I don't even know I don't really
know why it's called herringbone I bet
Roger knows because I bet they have
herrings and in Scandinavia hmm well I
have my ten thousand weave patterns and
herringbone is one of them um
okay we don't know why it's called that
okay um but but anyway so I mean you
know presumably these name things we
needed course mr. lammeter do you
wikipedia says so named for a fancy
resemblance to the bones of a fish such
as oh I see because it goes two ways
right because across the spine of the
fish so to speak the herring the bones
are yes I understand
it's like many herring stucked at many
herring skeletons where there's the
spine is in the middle of that okay I
get it
um Steve and Chris joins the meeting
okay good okay hey Chris we're talking
about some cross hatching and filling
patterns and so on and we want to know
why did I even have this did I just lose
this broken disc a dad was supposed to
be well I think that is bug and fun yeah
all right okay Chris what do you call a
thing that like fills with random stuff
in what what would you call that effect
I mean like like some of these things we
call cross hatching and so on what would
you call that effect if I was in
Photoshop Illustrator I would call it
pattern Phil I I'm not sure what I would
call it besides I obviously know nothing
other than that not for an arbitrary
sort of like yeah obviously if it's like
stripe stripe stripe I would call it
hatching but first like an arbitrary
okay Todd Phil I'm not sure all the time
I had what I would call been saying okay
all right fine but we're just saying
pattern Phil is the typical thing okay
yeah all right so look I think we should
we should start off for now call it
pattern felling we should really get I
think Tim will be well equipped here
Roger and so on to come up with a bunch
of named you know hatching patterns and
pattern fit so is hatching normally part
of pattern filling
No No who's saying yes who say no is
Chris saying no is Chris saying yes I
was saying yesterday I'm used to it we
say no because he's small I mean why do
Cassidy's and when you lose are those
like illustrator it's just the way they
build the hatching because they build it
from apart and feeling I say okay and
here we want on for size especially in
this case you know the anger because it
Nick you know one case one stand example
you had was bad shot but you have civil
band then you want to have different
hatching and one adventures was to use
the angle to make the distinction but is
not just a cost miss no I I agree I
agree well I don't know we have to try
it I think maybe and we need probably as
I see so what you've got here I don't
understand presumably we could have in
general a set of hatching lines at a
certain angle with a certain pitch at a
certain angle correct yes I don't know
what they look sensible for things other
than 90 degree angles does it or does it
just look silly it probably it know it
doesn't look sensible I I know what it
looks like I'll show you what it looks
like because I've actually studied this
for random reasons here I'll show you
something which which makes it
horrifying I'm gonna have to grow in a
minute okay shall we go on with this or
should we not go on with this Roger I'm
sure we don't
and then we contain I'll see if we can
have it scheduled then to continue
tomorrow soon tomorrow Thursday I just
like to point out to you unfortunately
Thursday I'm on a plane some part of the
day I'm just like to point out to you
that that's what happens
it's moiré patterns if you if you go um
said so this is this is hopeless for non
you know sort of irrational angles it's
just gonna get totally hopeless oh it's
very amusing but it's not going to be an
effect that one wants um okay
just have a quick look forward in this
meeting agenda if we could do is doing
is Chris here from design yes please um
I I don't know what this thus nearest
mesh sells and things that I'm sure
they're wonderful I'd really like to
look at them um what is this thing here
I don't quite understand what this is it
allows you to do geode compute with a
full geometry subsystem on Geographic
stuff so if you have geographic
coordinates in polygons
oh I future sense it's not ordinary
coordinates these are coordinates in the
Mercator projection or something right
then there are two modes this mode is
you want to actually compute on the map
and the other case you actually want to
compute on the globe
so you could argue that that you're only
interested in things on the map or
you're only interested in things on the
globe because things on the globe were
the true things but Bofur interesting
okay so this is geo position or a Geo
grid position which is the mapping
projected projected position very nice
okay I'm sure this is going to be easy
this but this is I'm optimistic about
this um okay supporting a bunch of new
things here around a man okay fine web
region search should we just have a
quick look at that so if I say web
region search rhinoceros for example
what's going to happen you're gonna get
a rhinoceros first I'm gonna get a bunch
of rhinoceros well that particular Wi-Fi
symbol is very hard I would have thought
we want dot dots but okay so there's
okay so let's pick one of those rhinos
that type click select first now okay so
let's
let's pick those two rhinos no ways okay
said copy/paste what the heck is this
it's a resource object do you know the
city Coriolanus I'm well aware of the
resource system okay good okay so are
you telling me so so you've put lots of
these no sauce data oh I see
so in general the way that resource
system that's a little odd that
interface if I might say so is that
going to be the mesh meshes yes does the
default property I think this interface
is odd and we should talk about it I
think we can make it smoother and now
the rhinoceros is kind of coming up
everything some rhinoceros are big I
don't um what the heck is it doing I
don't know if you got you too rhinoceros
but I don't see okay okay so these are
all licensing cleared objects that
people can use is that true just
depository okay and how many do we have
how many of we because these come from
our repository is that right order are
they coming from an API
but it's being it's being fronted by our
repositories that correct well no no so
essentially we have a connection
directly to the opposite or depending of
the API also we can do the search on
essentially we return the source object
to each Xavier referenced
that object on the external repository
nobody okay so the fact that you've got
a data repository icon there is
irrelevant yes yeah I've been talking
with forget the name to actually sick
start to change with having yet managed
fine but so this is a generic resource
object whose content location is an
external API and in the external API is
um is this random rhinoceros um
how absurdly non g-rated is the stuff
you get here I don't think you know I
don't really know wait Thingiverse I
don't think it's that Thingiverse is one
of the big collections well I mean I'm
just okay and that's used plenty of
places in education and so on so yeah I
don't think some of another repo store
is NASA and I don't think that they are
putting a bad stuff I'd err
NIH I don't think that they pro finally
buy it okay fine
the answer that is it's fine uh although
we might want to check if any of them I
am okay alright see you Roger but we'll
continue a little bit without you here
okay um okay so what I mean what kind
typically do with these things are they
are they too big to handle or they
typically have a reasonable size and do
we have any constraint on that and do we
down sample at all we don't usually have
a decent size most of them are 3d
printable so but so what I mean this one
look in the front end here this one is
gumming up all over the place right I
mean I'm not I'm having a hard time
pasting this in the front end somewhere
this livestreamer this is gonna end up
dead like financial data actually that's
about to come back to life again we
apologize for the interruption but much
of it has already come back to life for
financial data and all of it is coming
back very soon yes it is a big nuisance
dealing with a supply chain for some of
these assets um and it's much better
when we control the whole supply chain
but that's not the way the world works
um okay my question is I mean look I'm
oh my gosh well it's a very detailed
rhinoceros but I mean it seems
implausible that I can do anything to
this like for example if I try and take
that or be an example of something I
could do here take the bounding
circumspect something I could what's an
operation I can do on this let's believe
you volume or will the volume be zero
there's a problem or so you look at this
I mean I can't even type here John do
you want to comment on this well
something very strange is going on
because it pushed it right off the
screen which I don't have an explanation
for the rhinoceros was afraid but yeah
in general yes but is it I mean what
type of thing is needed to solve that
problem I mean I'm just wondering okay
fine so you can compute stuff on this I
mean when we have morphology of in
geometry for example we can down
sampling it before we
I said to Honda it so it's old stuff
become I would have thought that what
should happen here for this for most
applications of this is that we should
down sample like crazy because most
things I mean you know and have an
option here and I hate the term web
region search just hate it
um I think it should be geometry and I
think we should subcase the geometry but
I think that you know basically what
should happen is that just like let me
give you an analogy in web image search
we are basically returning thumbnails by
default because that's what people
that's what is typically wanted I mean
if I go I mean we I think it already
into our point one that's what's
happening I mean if I go web image
search I know Souris so let's see what
it does
see I mean we could return full scale
images but they would have all kinds of
restrictions and it will be hard to deal
with but we're actually returning
thumbnails so I'm saying and that's more
useful so I think we should do the same
thing here and and have some special way
of getting the full image you know full
region full mesh or something that makes
sense Charles yes but you want us to
return the image or the mesh first I
mean oh no the master chose to mesh mesh
but just the downsample mesh difficult
is it to down some porn not really but
we don't yet have that functionality we
don't have any form yet right I mean
that
okay so Bob is commenting that the 3d
rotation of this looked really slow and
it does seem really slow and why is it
slow why is this not that this is a
youtube question why is this long I
think there's a lot of if you click on
it and you look at the last one the
formation how many polygons you think
there are here thousands million million
Youssou is correct 1.3 million polygons
ok so that's an absurd thing to have put
into you know so it's not surprising
this is slow so you see who you you
believe that this is getting
state-of-the-art performance in terms of
rotation given that I think what are you
observe dance queen tears back there and
currently the prototype is using new
joining layer which is made her Mac so
it's it's yes dear experiment is that so
there there are some parks there but I
yeah maybe if you copy can you copy it
maybe I'm pasting 12 I think in 12 we're
reaching for millions decently I think
ok
by the way jar
continue to see that bug where sometimes
like one out of four times when I copy
it an image I'm not getting you know
only when the when I refocused the
window does it actually go in there did
you did you find that bug finally to be
honest I'm not remembering okay so
remember when if you do a screen capture
for example okay no that was a different
discussion that was in 12:1 okay so here
we go this is a great example I've got a
screen capture in my mouse okay
I press command-v nothing happens right
now I go you told me this trick I go
here yes
I go there and it suddenly pastes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I remember what you
talked about now what is that
I mean we got to find that bug well the
issue is that is that the front end is
not being properly notified about
somebody else changing the clipboard
because because there was no focus
change and it kind of was latching on to
the focus change on in terms of the Mac
implementation so I see so when screen
capture happens and it didn't there was
no focus change associated with the
screen capture doesn't know that the
club okay that at least explains it
yeah that can only happen basically with
that with the built-in screen capture
Wow
I wish you told me that years ago when I
first saw this bug okay well that at
least explains it but can we fix it I
think so I think so it's just that I'll
be honest I've kind of forgotten about
it I okay so address it is a filed issue
I know just got lost in the you know you
know in working on a bunch of the other
Mac stuff
okay so I want to know about this
rhinoceros because I'm moving I'm trying
to move it why is it changing sighs I
just moved my mouse down why why is it
zooming the thing you soo look look at
that I click it and the look at it it's
got my fingers are off the mouse it look
it looks like some kind of failure of
Terror rotation you agree you too right
it looks like something wrong yeah it
should be I will fix that okay do you
need this particular rhinoceros you can
go find it yourself I think okay yeah
yeah just take a screen capture of where
it was I'm not gonna send you the whole
thing it's too big just too yeah yeah um
oops sorry I closed it um okay but but
so so the answer is with 1.2 million
polygons it is rotating reasonably and
apart from the silly bug I mean that's
very nice that's very nice smooth
rotation I'm very impressed
apart from the silly sizing bug um yeah
and so to be clear this is the legacy
OpenGL renderer which you know isn't
really moving because apples stopped
doing anything with it but the metal
renderer which we're working on it's not
fully optimized yet but once it is it
should be faster did you tell me you
would you were telling me earlier I
think we didn't finish that conversation
about this Vulcan thing you're saying
that's that's poorly developed so far
the so-called crossed so claimed
cross-platform rendering layer
did you already plane that go ahead
sorry I'm not sure exactly what which
cross-platform rendering layer you
referring to this thing called Vulcan oh
so Vulcan is I mean it's basically the
you know kind of OpenGL the next
generation you know it's you know it's
it's the same people who are working on
it basically saying well if we started
over today and didn't have a legacy to
carry on how
we design a system but you know I mean
the issue with us is that we have
limited resources and four different 3d
rendering layers yeah and so you know
direct3d was non-negotiable because
that's that's really all the windows
wants to deal with you can do OpenGL but
it performs terribly and recently you
know Apple has made no official
statement about OpenGL but their
official statement is hey look the same
version of OpenGL has been in the last
four versions of the operating system so
pretty clear what statement they're
making there okay so let me make a
suggestion about this this web region
such thing okay so if you're saying
you're saying that it is difficult for
us to downsample this creature is that
correct but we don't have the Charles we
you were saying we don't have the
technology to do down sampling at this
time yes for this vessel well how far
away is down sampling it seems like a
hard problem so we can we can use all
right listen
putting this in it's going to just blow
everything up so the one thing I can
imagine is you could pre-select
when you actually doing the search for
which things to show here for ones that
have low polygon count see what I'm
saying
you got some ranking here the ranking is
kind of random what one is she essential
is that you don't really know if you've
gone cut the size of the object on until
you download it is that cause the
metadata and no really file size no it
depends on the repository on you know
what if I do want to provide okay but I
bet you could you could do something
which even before is it a web download
you can probably figure out the file
size before you web download it
nobody but that's what I would do
because I mean this is just gonna mess
everything up people are gonna try this
it's gonna fail they're gonna get things
with 8 million polygons in them which
are magnificent and reproduce every you
know hair on the nose of the rhinoceros
and things but blow their systems up
which just isn't very useful um okay
yeah I feel strongly about doing
something like that I mean I you know I
don't know how quickly you could get it
down sampling algorithm working but one
or one or other of those things has got
to happen I mean it may study that down
something is quite slow this we're
trying to see what we can do somebody is
asking whether the renderers that we saw
would work okay I gotta try it but I
cannot believe this will work if this
works I'll be just incredibly impressed
am I going to be impressed or am I gonna
be is it gonna be a total splat here I
can't even taste the pouring oestrus so
what would I do here I would say stipple
if it could only type here will help if
it goes to a new line oh my gosh this is
like this is like typing on a acoustic
coupled modems thing back in the 1970s
yeah sorry the stipple shading take any
arguments or is it just open closed the
stipple sure
didn't take arguments please thing to do
you can work with no argument I probably
need to go eight classic 3d yeah I'm
just doing predictive typing here I mean
I just I typed several seconds ago it's
good you know we developed those skills
back how many years ago it's always good
to know it's just like when I was a kid
I learned to type on a typewriter with
one finger cuz I wasn't strong enough to
type with all fingers on a typewriter
and then eventually cell phones came
along and then it was useful to know how
to type with one finger well amazingly
that actually worked that well done Utsu
look at that we got a stippled
rhinoceros what do you know okay is it
even gonna have any chance of saving
this file with it with all those
millions of polygons in it it will save
but it will take a while and it would
hang up Davian so just be aware of that
okay um alright downsampling bob on our
live stream is commenting would also be
useful in making computer games yeah I
mean downsampling really seems like a
very useful thing to have um well did
that successfully save what do you know
what better than we expected okay all
right
is anything else we can usefully cover
here without Roger humm
I don't think we can look at this right
now this has clearly got to come back
for another review
um yarn and
um yes but when I was typing before it
was rear-ended by rhinoceros every time
I typed a key and I agree the stippled
one appears to be rotating faster than
the unstapled one is that surprising to
anybody it's using OpenGL because I say
so this is the Unruh unoptimized metal
being used with this case and this is
using the optimized OpenGL
yeah because because right now the
shaders so that's another can of worms
is that going to be difficult to
reimplemented these traders and metal as
well in my son uses a long walk about
sir it's not that difficulty okay so
listen we are going to need to review
these some more I'm I guess I am
reluctantly partially I mean some of
these I don't have a problem with
stippling I think that's easy to
understand I don't know why hatch
shading it's a little weird that it's
hatch shading and then hatching
oisin
because of dashing watching dashing for
the 2d no no that's nice for 2d um and
shading is after all also a Oh what are
those things called oh my gosh what is a
word that ends in ing called
what is the part of the verb inflection
of the verb called gerund no it's not
the gerund the gerund is something
different okay I don't feel quite as bad
except that spent too much of my life
doing linguistic stuff I should know
this um okay anything else for right now
oh okay thanks a lot everybody lots of
nice stuff and thank you to focus on the
live stream good comments much
appreciated
All Right see y'all soon